مراسلنا بتحليق طائرات الحربيه في سماء
الخرطوم صباح اليوم بينما سمعت اصوات
انفجارات تدوي وسط العاصمه وشرق الخرطوم
بحري وقال مراسلنا انه سمع اصوات انفجارات
عنيفه وشهد تصاعد اعمده الدخان في سماء حي
الوابورات في مدينه الخرطوم بحري وفي محيط
القصر الجمهوري سمع دوي انفجارات عنيفه
واصوات اسلحه ثقيله استخدمت في الاشتباكات
من جنوب الخرطوم ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره
الطاهر المرضي هذا الصباح الامور اكثر
هدوءا الطاهر
وان كانت هنالك اشتباكات في الصباح في
منطقه الخرطوم بعد بالقرب من منطقه وبرا
وكذلك وسط الخرطوم ولكن الان هنالك هدوء
في هذه المنطقه لا توجد اشتباكات هدوء حجر
ايضا في جنوب الخرطوم بصفه عامه يبدو ان
الهدنه يعني يعني من حين الى اخر تحت تحدث
فيها اختراقات وهنالك تبادل للالتهامات
ايضا بين طرفي
الحرب في مثل هذه الظروف باعتبار ان هذه
الهدنه ليست لها اليه او جهه انت مراقبه
حتى تحدد من الذي قام باختراق هذه الهدنه
على كل ان هذا هو الوضع ولكن هي اجواء
الحرب هي التي تخيم على الخرطوم ايا كانت
الظروف والاوضاع الانسانيه ايضا
في حاله من التعقيد ان هنالك مظروف قاهره
في جنوب الخرطوم انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
لمده خمسه ايام وكذلك المياه وشحبه
السيوله وشح في الوقود واضح ان هذه الحرب
التي تدخل الاسبوع الثالث تنعكس بشكل سلبي
وتداعي على المواطنين في هذه المنطقه
الجوله التي يقومون بها هنالك واضح ان
تاثير على على المواطن في هذه المنطقه
بالنسبه لارتفاع الاسعار المواد الغذائيه
الحصول عليها كذلك قطاع التيار الكهربائي
يؤثر على تخزين
الاطعمه الانسانيه وكذلك صعوبه كبيره
نعم بالنسبه للمعارك والاشتباكات هل يمكن
ان نقول انها يعني في مناطق في مناطق
محدده في الخرطوم هل توجد اماكن اصبحت
اكثر امنا في العاصمه ايضا هل يمتد الصراع
خارج ولايه الخرطوم
بالنسبه للمناطق الامنه حتى الاحياء التي
الاحياء التي يعني فيها نوع من الهدوء
تزبط فيها الغازات من حين الى اخر وهذا
ايضا يؤثر بشكل كبير على الوضع الامني
بالنسبه للمواطنين والحركه ايضا في
الشوارع لكن المواطن يحاول ان يستفيد من
هذه الغده ويتمنى ان تكون هذه الهدنه
متماسكه حتى يستطيع ان يتعامل مع هذا
الوضع بشكل يعني يمكنه من الحصول على
احتياجات هي الاشتباكات كانت بالامس في
مدينه الابيض وهذا ما حدد منه البعض ان
تتسح هذه دائره دائره الحرب استمرت الامور
على ما هي عليه وان الحرب هي التي يعني
تسيطر وان البندقيه هي التي صوتها يعلو
حتى الان على الرغم من ان هنالك مبادره
سواء كان اقليميه من منظمه الايجاد او
دوليه من امريكيه
سعوديه ولكن حتى الان هذه المبادرات لم
خطوات عمليه بمعنى ان يتم تحديد من يمثل
الجيش السوداني والقاده الدعم السريع
وتحديد الدوله التي يمكن ان يفرضه اليها
للحوار سواء كان حول حول كيفيه وقت طويل
للمدى الى اطلاق الناس او حتى الى وقف
الحرب والدخول في مفاوضات لان هذه الحرب
يتحدث عدد كبير من من الخبريه يقولون ان
الحرب لا يمكن ان تنهي هذه الازمه بهذا
الشكل ربما تؤثر بشكل اكبر على البنيه
التحتيه بالنسبه للسودان وربما تدني الى
اندلاع حرب شامله بمعنى ان الامور الان
يمكن احتوائها بشكل او باخر حتى اذا وصلت
الاداره الامريكيه الى انها حددت بفرض على
من يقوم بعرقله التحول الديمقراطي او يقوم
باسكال نهر الحرب في في مثل هذه الظروف
وهي كلها هي جميعها الضغوط على طرفيه صراع
حتى يعني يذهبوا الى طاوله المفاوضات شكرا
جزيلا لك من جنوب الخرطوم الطاهر المرضي
مراسل الجزيره شكرا جزيلا